May God’s peace, mercy, and blessings be upon you. I have returned to you
again, Omar Mohsen or Omar Julio, in the
current lesson. I hope, God willing, that the course will be
simple for you. After we finished managing the management of
Jomla magazine, we finished the previous lesson. Let’s go back and see
from the beginning the control panel in which we finished all
the details. We finished groups and sections.
And others, we will go to add a new article in order to
add it to the Sections and Groups Manager. We will go
to add a new article and get to
know it simply like this. The first thing is the name is the title of the article. The name is a pseudonym, which is the title in which we must write “
Elias” as we see it, and it appears above
here in
the link and it must be in the Arabic language.
English language and without spaces. Sorry, it is published. This is the
status of the article. Is it published or not? If not, it will not appear
with us on the site.
If it is published, it will appear. Do you want it to appear on the main page or in the section only? If you want it to appear, we click on
Yes and Wendy. This is a simple example. If the article, for example, is the
written article.  Military Dit, as we see it. We make a
copy for her and transfer it. We put it
here. The pseudonym. We can write Egypt, for example,
or something about the article, elections, or something else. Egypt
New, as it is written like this. The section is the section
that we used to do in it before. We have
Arab and international news. We can write news.
The Arabic of the group is the subsection. We can
make it news, for example, the Gulf, because I made a
topic in the past. As for the classifications, the
situation is as we see. This is the visits post. If the topic has been done before, we will modify
it. If there are modifications, it will appear here. Everything will
appear here. As for here, the part or area remains.  In
which we will write our own article, if it will be a
copied article, or we can try it, for example, in the
part above this date, we
will put it as we see the article. Yes, it is simple and small. We want to make a word as we see it,
or leave it with a line under it or
with a line on it as we see it.  Do you see it like this? Or
left and right. We want to align the space with the
text. We want to change the type of font or
style. Make the font
bigger or small. We want to control it also
from here. We want to do a punctuation for the paragraphs
that we have created. Or punctuate the right or leave it to the
left. We want to do anything we do. We want to
do it.  Link, for example, on the topic Dot. We will stay from
here and write the link we want,
for example, here is its text. Will the link open on the
same page or will it open on a new page on the
same page? The address on the link
will be what it looks like, under the link or above the
link. In my journey, we will notice that it is.  Its color has changed. It remains
in the link. We want to remove
the link. We know about it. We click on
this. I will remove the link. We return it again. If we want to add a new image to the article, we click here and put the link to the image from here. A description of the image and its location
remains right and
left. For example, we go, for example,
to create a copy of the location in order to get the
link.  We want
to make
a description of the image, for example, a simple description of the image. We want its
alignment to be right, left, left,
center. Let it be, for example, if you see the spaces or dimensions of the image. How will it be treated?
In order for it to appear with us, let
it be, for example, 200 in.  200 We want to make a frame for it.
For example, we leave the frame for three. We want to make a
space between it and the words, right and left. We make it,
for example, seven and seven, and we make an arc. We
will notice that the picture is surrounded, and it remains in a space on the side, above, and
right next to the article. It is possible that if
we want to reduce it a little, let it be 150, for example,
by 120, we will notice.  If it remains in the middle of the text,
as we see, leave it in the middle, there is no
problem. We will not need it. We want to add the HTML language
with us in the
topic. Here, simply if we want to create a ruler
or a space between one part or another part, for example, we
talk about two parts in the article, we want to erase
the space that we made.  We want to
put under the word under the word, for example, seven, under as
we see that, or above, there is an S,
for example, all simple things, and God willing, there will be no
problem with you. If we want to detail the
important part here, if we want to add
a picture
of our place or the manager that we
explained in  Before the multi-link manager, we click
on inserts, and if we want to upload an image from our
device, we also make inserts
from here and see what it looks like. The image is framed and we also control it from here. If we want to control a cell, for example, in the bottom
bottom and control the dimensions and everything in it, we
can pull it like this and leave it above or  We control
as we want.
When our article appears in the main page, it shows the text of the article,
for example, or part of it. After that, it reads more. We
press this button. We will notice that it is in a line.
If we want to separate one page from the
second page, we click on the page separator. We create colors and
we do not need them.  Nowadays, all things are
very simple. This was for the part of publishing a
new article. As for the writer, if we want to
show the writer we are, we used to work for two. A writer works for Mohamed
Sayed, the general manager.
If we want, Mohamed Al-Sayyed is the one who writes it. If
we want to give him a pseudonym, for example, a designer or a
professional.  Internet, for example, what is the level of access? Anyone
can reach it if only the first registrant or no one
will reach it. If we want to modify the date of creation,
date of publication, the end of publication after a certain period, it
begins. We choose from here and choose the date
we want, after which publication ends. The
instructions remain the date of what we were.
We set it in the publishing options for all
members. The general will be used. It is automatic. It uses
what we used to do. If we want to change
something else, we change it, such as the name of the writer. It appears.
Hide or
show the descriptive information, which is the description of the topic. We
write, for example, what topic we are talking about, for example, Egypt
and the state of the elections. It helps us, of course, in the
engines.  Search as a description, for example, elections, everything
related to the topic, we write it, and if we want a
specific link, we find a specific writer, we write it. Of course, we will not
need these things after that. We can do
a preview, save the article, or apply, and we will prefer in the
article if we want to prepare anything after that, or
cancel, we will remove everything we want.  We did it by saving it and
noticing that the topic was put down to ours, which is the
military one as we see it. I
made articles for you before, so that it would be
quick. I did an article in America and an article in
Europe. The sections I was making were all
international news, Arab news, and one under the
pseudonym that we write.  One with the name of this
and one with the name of the manager so that it remains in the group. We
want to start showing the rest of the specific topics
and it does not appear to be a waste of meaning. From here we show everyone
who is in the Arabic news category. We click
on all of them. They appear. We click on everyone
who is in the world news that appears. We click on the inside of
international news in groups, for example, a group.
Europe, but a group will appear as we
see. This is very simple if you want it. If you want,
only articles written in the name of a manager who
will bring you all the articles in a published or unpublished status. If, for
example, we mark here to cancel the
publication, it is no longer published or leave it published. If you do not
want, in the main page, click here.  We can make
all the arguments very simple, or we can mark the
article and make it, for example, unpublish. We can
copy it and repeat it twice, or move it to another section if
this section is not in its place, or leave it in the archive, or
return it again, or delete it. Edit things are all
very simple. This is how we made the articles, and
God willing, the lesson will be.  It's simple.
After that, the next step is that we go back to our
site's control panel. We will start making
lists, because now we have finished the
topics and articles and made sections. After that, inside them are
sub-sections or groups and we have created
articles inside them. We will start making the rest of the
lists so that we link them to the lists manager so that
we create a new list.  We will find that we have only
one list, and it contains the general one. We are concerned about it so that we can
make lists that contain something new other than the general one,
as we remember. Like the mini menu, it only had the general one. We will do the rest of the Arabic news and link it to what we were doing a
while ago and go to the
new one in order to make lists or sub-menus
for the mini menu.  Our main interface will show us
the interface, and this interface, of course, is not easy
to recognize easily. I will leave it in the next lesson
so that there is 100% concentration. I want you to
open your mind with me, and God willing, the topic will
not find anything difficult at all. It is a very simple sentence,
but this may be the problem you are facing.
Many people write their magazine in
a sentence and come to Wordpress or Blogspot
or something like that, but there is a sentence in it. I swear it is very good options, God willing.
Wait for me in the next lesson. May the peace, mercy, and
blessings of God be upon you. Don’t
forget to subscribe to the channel and like and share
so that everyone
can benefit.